how's it going guys Matt here with code
Tech tutorials today we're going to look
at C plus plus and talk about return
types this is sort of a beginner type of
thing so a lot of you might already know
this but uh if you don't necessarily or
you just want a refresher stay tuned
alright so I'm using Windows here and I
opened visual studio and we're doing a
cmake project so that's the the setup
there and we're just going to hit next
here and we're going to go return type
demo so just a quick uh place where I
can put some code while I talk about
this stuff all right so return types
what I mean by return types is basically
when you write a function
you often want to return some kind of
variable or some kind of object or
sometimes just modify one so I want to
talk about the main ways this is done
and that's basically going to be the
video okay so we got our main here and
Main is a function that returns an
integer notably so that's that's the
main most standard way is to just you
know you have the return type here
before your function declaration and you
return something that matches 0 is an
integer so that'll be happy but
um often you want to do special things
with functions like uh let's let's make
a little
maybe a little game setup type thing
let's say for example I'm gonna make
this a very contrived basic example to
start let's say we want to make a player
character maybe we're trying to make a
little game and we don't have hit points
and stuff like that I like these kind of
examples because they're often easy for
people to wrap their head around and not
necessarily so abstract all right so you
think all right we have a player we want
uh HP and maybe we'll do this as a float
and we want float let's go with the
action points but maybe action points
are more set in stone so we don't want
to flow to point on that and we just
want an integer and maybe we have
something like uh well let's go with
string here we have a player name that
you can set you know just some basic
stuff and let's let's be sure to include
string over that
so hpe action points and maybe we'll
have a few other things like
um strength the intellect sure now just
a couple in let's fill these out
strength just a few stats to play around
with and let's play this it points out
too but hit points are going to be
afloat and we'll go with this style so
there's like all our player stuff and I
know this uh already has some stuff that
you're probably right off the bat
thinking oh that can be approved but
we'll get to that for the sake of
example we're going to start it out like
this say you know you don't really want
to make your program complicated you
just want to have one file and so
whatever you declare globals you think
this is fine for now which I mean it's
going to work if it works that's the
majority of the battle so maybe it is
fine and let's say you want to go into
your game and the first thing you want
to do is like set your hit points and
you want to set all your stats so you'll
do something like uh player name equals
uh I don't know let's do a get line and
have them take input for that all right
so here's copy illusion and uh since C
plus plus 11 emits copy Constructors
resulting in zero copy pass by value
semantics so these are called pass by
value when you're not doing a reference
like get line was get line takes in
player name by reference so it's going
to be pretty guaranteed to not make a
copy however this uh this is going to
make a copy so so we're kind of looking
at like you know some function T is just
some type here when you call it it's
going to return the type constructed
but it's going to make a copy but
however this one here now this kind of
gets into some some deeper stuff that I
don't necessarily want to complicate
this episode with but the basic Point
here is there are cases when it's going
to still make a copy and there are cases
where it's going to properly move your
data
and
not necessarily make a copy and you
basically kind of have to study this and
fully understand it to know whether it's
doing that or not so in general it's
probably not the best thing to rely on
this little feature because well it's
also going to just differ in different
compilers so if you're sharing your code
your results may vary in different
places so what we can do instead
is well we've got the return type of a
float but we could also just return void
and we could take in the hit points it's
a float take it in by reference and just
call it HP here it doesn't need the same
name and we can just set it to that HP
equals 10. and that way it's taken in a
reference so it's not making a copy
there and it's just setting it and since
it's a reference it's the real variable
and that would work as well so we just
and rather than put it over here for the
return side we just pass it in here and
that might be a slightly better way of
doing it and we can propagate that and
do these the same way however we're
going to get a whole bunch of functions
after a while and if you know all of
them are just set default whatever
action points so on
rather than returning we've got this
method this is essentially called a
return to usually when people make
functions like this they preface these
variables something like out that way
it's clear when you're reading the code
especially if it's a huge function that
this is essentially an output now if you
don't want this to be an output but you
still don't want to copy in the variable
you could make market const and then
const will not allow it to be changed so
this will result in a compiler error so
you can still keep your function
efficient by not making copies and these
pass in values Now by doing that but if
you've got to change it then can't make
it const
and let's go hit this this should be an
end and you can kind of Imagine
um of all this AP out AP
and kind of imagine how you could
propagate the rest of these and do it
essentially the same way so there's two
methods of doing it you either pass it
in by reference and set it in the
function or you just return it and
either are pretty much okay the return
over here just risks making a copy
unless you're really up on exactly how
you're handling everything now you can
do tricky stuff like
um you can return a reference to a float
for example and do the same function and
not take anything there and then just
say return n.f
and that's a valid function too it's
going to return a reference to this but
this is actually rather confusing
because this is just in a local space
this might even error out I don't know
let's let's see what it does
let's see what happens here we'll set it
to 20 there so if we call this function
and there's a bit of a
the functions are the same name but
since they have different signatures
here it will know which one we're
talking or we're talking about all right
so here we should see that hit points is
20 but we can also
you know you got to think about this
over returning a reference to this 20.
uh what is going to happen there I don't
know let's find out and I would
definitely encourage you to experiment a
lot with code like this if you're not
sure what's going on just uh check it
out and see what happens and there's an
error and it can't convert this float to
a reference to a float so there's a
little bit narrative but if we just get
rid of this reference then it's going to
be fine that'll do it
player name ASDF there's the HP so that
worked so you you can while you can
return references you're not going to be
able to in general return a reference to
something you've created in the function
it would have to be something outside
like let's say up here we have a float
called uh I don't know default hit
points
then and we set this right off the bat
to 20 and uh we could make it const jpr
if we want but what if we return this
could we return this by reference I
don't know let's have a let's have a
check so notice it's not being declared
on the function this is just something
that's just always in your program
basically since it's Global there and it
also fails again it can't return const
float to a float and let's take off the
const stuff see what happens then
it works and you still get 20. so you
can do stuff like that too because uh
you know you're able to get a reference
from it and it stays it stays around the
problem with creating it in the function
and then trying to return a reference to
it well once this goes out of scope it's
going to delete all this stuff with uh
the cleanup
and it's no longer going to be sticking
around so it's not even going to know
what the reference is it's just going to
be to some kind of dangling I guess it
would some be something like a dangling
pointer I can't remember what it's
called in this exact case so there's
that let's uh I guess I should mention
some pointer stuff too like what if for
example we wanted to go okay let's set
default hit points but what if we just
want to take
uh we want to take a pointer to our HP
so what what is this going to do now HP
equals I don't know we'll say 30 in this
case it should all be the same if
they're all defaults but I'm just
changing the numbers for sake of uh this
different CL stuff all right so what
happens here if you try to call it with
that one all right so let's uh comment
these out for a second go set default
hit points
and functions all have the same name but
we know if we pass in just the HP it's
going to use this one if we don't pass
in anything it's going to use this one
if we pass in a pointer to a float it's
going to use this one so let's pass in a
pointer to a float and then you might be
saying oh but wait
um our float is not a pointer currently
what you have to do is put a and symbol
in front of it here and that will make a
pointer to it
and so then in that case we'll be
passing in a pointer to our hit points
it's not the exact variable we're not
passing in the variable we're passing in
a pointer to our variable so through
that pointer we can still get to the
real variable but not like this that's
going to throw an error let's just hit
play and show the error and it'll say
cannot convert float to float star so
what do we do here well we know that in
this case right here that this one is a
pointer and we can't just set it
directly to a float what we have to do
is dereference it by putting a star in
front of it and that says no uh it says
whatever it's pointing to basically so
if you have a pointer and you
dereference it with another one of these
Stars it points to the real variable
again so that should work and we should
get a 30 let's see if that works another
random name and 30. there it is so
that's another way you can pass in now
this isn't quite as efficient as passing
in by reference because when you pass in
by reference you're uh you know I might
be mistaken in this so correct me if I'm
wrong when you're passing in by
reference you're just you're passing in
the real variable basically or a
reference to it which might create a
pointer under the hood I'm not entirely
sure but it's pretty darn efficient
because if you've got some big object
you're not passing in the whole thing
you're just passing in a reference to it
which is just basically a pointer but
not actually a pointer but techno I
don't know it's kind of weird basically
it's just a small thing that says here
it is kind of like a pointer except uh
you know it I think obfuscates to the
real thing whereas when you're passing
in a pointer it's known as the data type
of being a pointer to that object so
you've got to dereference it to get the
real thing so this one here definitely
creates a pointer and then you've got a
D reference to the pointer which is a
little bit more work so this is probably
a tiny bit less efficient but these are
pretty much on par for some of the most
efficient ways to return stuff without
making accidental copies this also works
too but this is a little more dangerous
because
we we don't don't necessarily know the
lifetime of these hit points so if the
lifetime of this hit points changes then
we could be in trouble because uh if
that gets deleted or something then we
we really have no idea what it's doing
so we could mess around with this a
little bit more we could say it's a
float pointer and let's set it equal to
a new float 20. so it'll do that at the
startup can we still return a reference
to it like this uh not quite but if we
go what would we have to do I think we
put a star in front of it to dereference
this
and then we should be able to do it that
might work
all right so let's let's try that out
let's compile again
use that function
it's going to be this one here
and it's going to go off of this here
and let's see what happens there
it works and it does the right thing
so you might ask okay why that's really
weird why uh well because we're
dereferencing it and then we're just
returning a reference to this this hit
points variable in there so a lot of
jumping around the memory maybe
unnecessary in this case but this
happens a lot in program okay but the
problem is
problem with this function is what if
someone goes in your main what is the
first thing they do is they go delete
default hit points and now
there's nothing there it's gonna it's
gonna void out the memory it's not
technically going to void out the memory
it's basically going to say this points
to nothing or this points to an area of
memory that we don't necessarily know
what's guaranteed to be if you really
want to make it zeros you know even in
this case this area of memory might
still be the same thing but this pointer
is not going to be necessarily pointing
to the right spot I think that's correct
so we could say that this equals null
and then it would definitely be nothing
that's usually what you do when you
delete you delete it and then you set
the memory that's pointing to to zero
because the memory that's pointing to
doesn't necessarily change when you
delete it just makes
a random kind of random stuff it's not
it's not known anymore so like this here
even though we delete it this might
still work correctly because this area
still might end up being memory that's
20 but there's no guarantee of that and
your program doesn't know that anymore
so it's undefined so let's try it I
think we'll actually get 20. nope we
don't we get some random stuff so we put
different stuff in the memory it's
basically an area that's marked as free
by your operating system and who knows
what your operating system is going to
put in there but if it doesn't end up
putting anything in there you could
still end up with 20 which is why it's
undefined so that's the problem with
this is someone could delete this area
and then this function doesn't work
correctly anymore so you got to be
careful with that stuff that's generally
why you avoid this type of stuff and uh
you know once again if we just wanted to
be super safe like this function right
here just returning this
that's still going to be fine it's
probably not going to make a copy thanks
to copy illusion we don't have to waste
our brain power thinking of a million
different things about what could happen
it's just hey we want the float it
Returns the float all right that's uh
that's all well and good so let's go a
little further here all right what if
you want to set multiple things at once
what if you want to have a just like a
set all defaults what options do we have
there
all right so I'm going to get rid of
this I don't really want to mess with
that what if we just want to set all the
bolts and it's like what we want this
function to do is set all the player
defaults
like uh whatever those end up being
okay so we could you know these are
Global so we could just like pass them
in here like this and set them all
since they're Global and if this is all
like one big class or something maybe
this is something that's fine unknown
name I'm gonna type fast and typo things
I don't care uh default hit points 10
action points 10 strength intellect 10.
you know essentially they're all tens we
could just chain them and set them all
something you can do in C plus like that
and set all those to 10. so call and set
all defaults would update these globals
but that's uh you know that's not
necessarily something we necessarily
want to do like what are these what if
these aren't Global when we're declaring
them in our main then this isn't going
to work because it's not going to have
access to that stuff so we would have to
pass it in it's like okay that's fine
let's pass it in now let's go spring uh
let's do it by reference so we can
actually edit it by your name it's
getting and it's going to get real messy
and then we're gonna go uh float by
reference uh hit points pass that in you
know and we just go on and on and we
basically go down the line and pass
those all in so we could do that
or you know we could have it's going to
get a little messy is what I'm getting
to it's going to be a lot of code and
I'm going to show you a way that we
could kind of save code because this
would just go on we also want to bring
in uh the analect by reference so we can
set that and this would work
I'll just type it out strength by
reference so we can set that action
point by reference so we can set that
and uh and we could just call it so I'm
going to comment out all this code for a
second so we don't really need it
and we'll go set all defaults then we
gotta pass in all this stuff telesense
has not helping me out much here usually
it does it points action points
ranks
intellect so it'll pass all those in by
reference it'll set the real one since
they're invite reference they're not con
so it's allowed to and that will
actually work so let's uh I don't know
let's uncomment some of these lines so
that we can see what some of them are
set to I'm not going to do all of you
know we'll just look at HP name we
should see unknown and 10 for those so
let's hit play on that I've got an error
somewhere I can type out hit points okay
let's copy it down there we go
all right there we go we get the name in
HP it actually edited it so that's
another way you can do it you can just
pass it in by reference but I'll show
you yet another way that is often very
handy so we have our player and all this
stuff is tied together so this is a
great case for making a struct all right
so let's declare a struct up here for
player let's copy it up here and
construct
um we'll just call it a player and just
close in with brackets and there we go
now we have an object of a player that
holds all of this stuff
okay now that we have this full player
set up here it's just a struck it's just
a single object or it can be so now we
could make this a lot more simple with
the set defaults for example set
well defaults rather than having to pass
in every single one of these we could
just pass in the player struct once and
then call all the same stuff but we do
have to put some preferences in front of
it like uh player dot player name now
since it's part of the struct I guess uh
player name is redundant when it's
already a struct code player
uh so maybe we'll just change that
but uh you know you probably get the
point here so now we're still taking it
in by reference but we'll just we're
just doing it all at once rather than
having to type it out so it depends on
your function you know if it's something
that you want to edit an entire
instructor class you can do it like this
but if it's always going to be kind of a
mishmash of things depending on your API
or your program you might have no choice
but to do it something like this but you
can also see that like the problem with
this original one is well we can't just
return one thing so we can't do this
style because we can't return all this
stuff you're only allowed one return
type so if you need multiple return
types you often just have to pass a
bunch of stuff in by reference like this
and once again these should all be
prefaced with like an output you know
compiler doesn't care about that it's
just for reading purposes so you could
also do now with this set all defaults
like where here you can't return all
this stuff on the left side this one you
could so you could have a set all
defaults it takes nothing
and returns a a player or I guess it
would be like uh make default character
or something set all defaults and so it
works so well make defaults let's go
with that so make folds that return to
player and then we could uh you know we
could make a player in here cut all the
stuff
return player
so that would also work and then uh
rather than having to do this we could
just well there's multiple ways we could
do it we could go player make a new
player here make a new object and right
away we could just call make defaults
and that would set up our player
let's do a couple quick sea outs here
this would be
layer Dot name now
and player dot hit point so just make
sure to actually set them okay so we
could do it that way call on this make
defaults and we'll do the other one in a
second just the test uh we got an error
what's the problem said make defaults
not found no we have an s on it all
right could not do that
all right and there we go we got the
unknown name in HP 10 that it took from
make defaults so the other way of doing
it by passing it in do it that way too
it uh be this one here set all defaults
it wants a player reference so we go set
all faults
that's in our player now if it just
wants a reference you just need to make
sure it's not a pointer basically so you
just pass in the real thing like that
same thing works fine all right and
another thing maybe one of your player
or object be a pointer so you go like
this equals a new player you know call
Constructor then you want to pass in by
reference wait you can't see watch here
because it's going to have an error it's
going to say could not convert or no
overloaded function to convert all the
argument types because it wants a real
thing here so all we have to do is just
like before since this is a pointer and
we want the real thing we dereference it
and then it'll work or not
oh now that it's a pointer it wants this
here later
is this also dereferences if you go over
look up what this little symbol here
does basically puts a star in front of
it on the back end
and just to prove that basically you
could do this instead instead of using
that little thing but this it's a little
harder to read but it would work the
same uh what are we doing here oh I
think you gotta surround it by this
first if I'm not mistaken yeah
because basically we have to cast this
uh pointer to a non-pointer version and
that's my parentheses otherwise it
doesn't do the right order
so yeah in general they just made it
this little symbol here to de-reference
everything
all right well there's some examples so
hopefully get you started and get you
understanding some return type stuff and
things ways to call functions to edit
your variables I think that's enough for
this episode let me know your comments
down below any other tips anything that
I maybe missed I tried to kind of cover
everything but it's kind of impossible
to cover everything but I think I
covered the basic so if you got any
tricks or things you like to do when
changing stuff and functions let me know
and just to quickly summarize I would
say passing in by reference is often the
most efficient way to do it so that's a
lot of times what you want to do if
you're returning just a variable you
want to just make sure it's not copying
unless you're okay with a copy and you
just got to really pay attention to what
it's doing with the memory in a lot of
these cases like uh when you're passing
a pointer you can you know you could and
some I didn't cover you could also
return a pointer and do something along
the lines of this I guess I'll cover it
real quick and you make a float I don't
know because oh this was a 20 let's do a
20 dot app here uh
I guess this would be like a value
whatever all right so and then what if
you want to return value well that's not
going to work because it's not a pointer
but you could put a reference in front
of this and return a pointer to it but
what's the problem here can you think of
it I'll give you a second
all right the problem here is we're
returning a pointer to this value but as
soon as we hit the end of the scope as
value is getting deleting so deleted so
this will be a dangling pointer 100 of
the time this won't work at all you'll
you'll have a giant bug in your code so
uh be careful with that if you're not
sure how something works my best advice
would be in general to do it in a way
you know Works especially if you're new
uh so because a lot of times you just
want your program to work right so don't
introduce things that you don't
understand in general it sounds like
like this if you don't understand that
this value is getting deleted and you're
returning a reference to it while this
is an efficient this is a very efficient
return style because it's just returning
a small piece rather than the entire
float or an entire object it's very
buggy it would would work a little
better if it were something like this or
just Global and it stayed in scope and
never let scope then this would pretty
much work but if someone changed this uh
somewhere just randomly in your program
then it would return a different value
so you got to be careful stuff like that
all right I guess I guess I just wanted
to get a quick mention of returning a
pointer as well in there all right well
hope you enjoyed the episode uh let me
know if you want this code I think this
code is simple enough to type up or
follow along that I feel like I don't
need to upload it but uh yeah also this
just kind of makes the point of if
you're not sure what something does open
up your editor and start testing some
stuff out and play around a little bit
all right I'll see you in the next one
maybe we'll do a part two where we talk
more about like copy illusion and some
other little nuances and side cases if
you guys are interested let me know and
I'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign